In our Health
lead, the
Sesame Street
word of the day is trauma dump.
Okay, that's two words.
But Elmo learned all about trauma
dumps on Monday
after he asked
a seemingly simple question
on X, formerly known as Twitter.
Elmo is just checking in.
How is everybody doing?
Turns out everybody is not okay.
And by everybody, I mean
seemingly everybody.
Elmo was flooded with responses.
One reply reads, Elmo,
I'm depressed and broke.
Another says every morning,
I cannot wait to go back to sleep
every Monday.
I cannot wait for Friday
to come
every single day
and every single week for life.
Elmo heard from companies
including Oreo cookies, which wrote
ran out of milk.
Do the math.
Elmo heard from the Detroit Free Press
right after the Lions on Sunday
blew that huge game writing, quote,
We've been better, Elmo.
Look, times are tough out there.
Every single person
is fighting their own battles
big and small.
As for Elmo himself,
the Muppet followed up with this post.
Wow.
Elmo is glad he asked.
Elmo learned that it is important
to ask a friend how they are doing.
Elmo will check in again soon. Friends.
Elmo loves you
and the one and only.
Elmo joins us now
along with his friend, Samantha moulton,
executive vice president and chief
marketing and brand officer of Sesame
Workshop, Elmo and Samantha,
thank you
both for venturing
outside of Sesame Street
to talk to us today.
Elmo, it was very thoughtful of you
to ask all of us how we're doing.
So after all
you've been through this week.
Let me begin by asking you both,
how are you doing?
Elmo Oh, I think it's a lost.
And now that's a very important thing
to ask people and master to.
What am Elmo's doing really well.
You know, I was glad
that he was able to talk
to a lot of his friends
about how they're feeling.
It has certainly been a whirlwind.
Over 180
million people have seen Elmo's question
How are you?
And we've been spending time
developing resources and videos,
shows and activities
that parents can do together
with their children
to help them understand
how to talk about their emotions,
everything from belly breathing.
Elmo,
which you can teach our friends at home
how to do to sometimes
more traumatic issues
that they're dealing with.
Elmo, were you surprised
by all of the responses?
And why do you think this simple question
coming from you,
Elmo, resonated with so many
human beings and adults?
Well, you know,
I was not really sure I was surprised
because I do realize that
when you ask someone how they're doing,
you have to be ready
because maybe
someone is not doing you well,
maybe somebody is.
But that is an important question to ask.
And then Elmo's learned a lot about that.
I think this just speaks
to the special relationship that Elmo has
with our friends, with our audience,
and that really Sesame Street has that.
So many have grown up with Sesame Street
or are watching it today
with their children.
I'm one of those kids that grew up
watching Sesame Street.
I was born in 1969.
I think that's
when you guys were founded.
And and and although Elmo,
you hadn't yet moved to Sesame Street
when I was watching.
But that's when Sesame Street
was started to be around.
Yeah.
Elmo, when you're feeling down,
what helps you feel a little brighter?
Well, you know, one of the things
that you were just talking about
was barely breathing,
which is a really important strategy.
That's a big word
that Elmo just knowing
that strategy and it's barely breathing.
So what you do
is you put your hands in your belly
and you breathe in through your mouth.
Is not this.
And then you breathe
out through your mouth slowly like this.
And that really helps
to make you feel calm
and sort of get centered and relaxed.
I feel better.
Do you?
Yeah. Yeah.
Well, it's it's.
I feel better just talking to Elmo.
Elmo,
I understand
you have a birthday
coming up this Saturday. Happy birthday.
How are you going to celebrate?
Maybe a cookie cake
with Cookie Monster If.
If he would let you have any.
I'll have crazy with.
You know, Cookie Monster
doesn't have cookies,
but he's very good at sharing.
Yes. Yeah, he's invited.
Everybody's invited.
You can come too, if you want to. It's.
I said it's so sweet.
We've got a big birthday
celebration planned for Elmo.
We're very excited about it.
And we're going to be releasing
some new resources for people
who really need them next week as well.
So Elmo is going to help us do that.
That sounds wonderful.
Elmo and Samantha Maltin,
thank you so much.
And please
give my best to Ernie and Bert and Kermit
and Grover and Cookie
Monster and Big Bird and Snuffleupagus
and the Count and Guy Smiley
and you know, the whole gang will do.
Anybody says hello, especially God.
Smiley. And he would like a job at CNN.
Okay, Jake,
I guess
if we could just remind everyone
to check out
those important resources at Sesame
dot org,
can learn about our emotional well-being
and you can learn
about all the great work
that Sesame is doing for communities
and how you can help support that.
And you can see
Smiley's resume on the website here.
Sounds good, Elmo.
Samantha, thanks to both of you.
I love a good dog